hi we're L seraphim I'm Yen I'm Kaz I'm
sakur I'm and we're here to do the wired
autocomplete
interview has the group ever Googled
themselves oh yeah all the time every
time every
time what does the seraphim mean it's an
an I'm fearless which is the motto of
our team M very Fearless dauntless girl
what does the seraphim call their
fans what is
Unforgiven the seraphim
about
okay yes what is the seraphim workout
it was a workout that we did when we
were preparing for the groove it was
like our training workout it was very
strenuous it was 100 jumping jacks as a
warmup and then 100 burpees and
then three sets of four different plank
exercises with 25 reps and stuff it was
very intense and we did that like like
for 2 hours twice a day but it helped us
build the stamina for our
Coro bye
thank you how
larapin how to pronounce
ler no
not
Japanese and for
English at the beginning of her career
people didn't know how to like write the
in Korean so it like people would write
as Le and it would be le seraphim
oh my God what was that one larim oh my
God how did Las seraphim
form fate your seraphim documentary true
Che it out check it out we have a
documentary about
our how long did the seraphin members
train o this is different for
anybody two years two years I was like
like I think in total like four years
she was very short like six months six
months
wow yeah for sakur is very hard cuz she
was an idol for 12 years now very wide
range
of okay last question how tall is the
Lin members okay recently grew though
she's still growing still growing me too
really oh congratulations thank you so
much how tall how
tall and I'm
172 so tallest
58 toss it toss
it
larapin who owned larapin
Fearless
era I
think and also I think Sakura cuz I
remember you got a lot of praise for
your dance
dancing yeah everybody had their own
expression of fearless cuz we all that
was like the first song we did together
after living very very different Lives
who La seraphim
[Applause]
zum or is it talking
about
so we use zoom often we called Zha from
when um she was in the Netherlands so we
had yeah that in our documentary but we
then we also talked to n Rogers over
zoom and then we also have this content
segment where we debate
nonsense things on Zoom so maybe let
talk about that who is the best dancer
in Las serapan
oh well we have a professional ballerina
in our
[Applause]
group
yes she's very good at
dancing I'm a
mess love your's life I'm a miss I'm a
miss oh yeah it's um talking about how
I'm a mess yeah I'm a mess I'm still
andess still the best dress yeah you're
last we don't dress you're impress Las
seraphim zodiac signs P ddy ddy Miracle
T and I'm a tting Dy I'm a Libra bye-bye
bye me byebye
by I would hait
you is
hen an opera singer it's oh my God it's
true I was not an opera singer but I did
sing classical music for a lot of my
life so I was in like choir and stuff
very famous
video
yes oh my God can I do it now I just had
hot sauce so
not the highest now kind of what does Hy
Jin like huh what do I like I like many
things lately I've been into
um lately I've been into
reading was in produce 48 oh my
God 18 years yeah yeah I think it was
the same age as you she used to watch me
which is crazy p and Jin love you twice
meaning oh what does it mean it means H
I've never talked about this song in
English before so this is cool love you
twice is about like all the seasons
change but I hope to be in your life
like a Four Season always blooming
flower I guess it's just like wanting to
be that
omnipresent Everlasting existence it's a
very sweet song mhm about my special
people in my life yeah
yeah oh you Saka Miaki is Saka Miaki a
wrestler
that's
crazy why is Miaki hakura why so
popular so many reasons tell me Google
tell me Google I don't know I think it's
because of her mom oh she's always
hardworking
and
I think that is truly a big reason why
she's so lovable Sakura Mii
signature okay Kaza Nakamura Nakamura
who is kaz's best
friend from the
[Applause]
documentary H issue yeah what is kaz's
favorite food chip chip
she's
favorite
yeah I mean abs abs for days what is
kazza
wearing biker
short outfit New Girl New Girl Kevin cry
Kevin cry Kevin
cry always thank you honor
bye what is
favorite color so many so many colors
red blue
yellow icons
[Music]
icons
so
cute
smile
smile po yeah smile potato you know the
potato like the fries with the smile
like punched into it she REM resembles
that so that was her first nickname that
we gave her all right thank you bye my
smile this was so fun if this was an
interview that we've always wanted to do
so it's so exciting to have been able to
do it today next time we hope that we
can come as five with our so if you're
watching we love you and we hope to see
you again thank you thank
you